Well, yes, vocabulary is certainly very
important, but
even if it's not the most appropriate word for the situation, such as "breakfast" instead of "breakfast", most of the time you
'll be able to convey it without any
problems.
If you try to force a
word that doesn't appear in your daily conversation, I think you'll end up withdrawing a lot of Japanese people.  If
anything, people are more
concerned about whether the other person is trying to use a polite way of speaking, so I think it would be good to focus on studying vocabulary after that.
Well,
honorifics and manners are very important, but
there are many Japanese who don't use honorifics when talking to foreigners, and there
are many Japanese who can't use the correct honorifics in the first place, so you do
n't have to study honorifics that much.  As a foreigner,
I may be saying that,
but in this day and age where everyone uses social media on a regular basis,
reading ability is very important, so studying kanji is much more important
than studying honorifics.  I
think it will be useful
Stroke order is also essential
Well, kanji is very important, isn't it
?  There are a lot of people who don't know what to say, and so does the teacher.
So this is my personal opinion.
I think we should focus on grammar and pronunciation. I'm
going to be a bit harsh, but
there are a lot of people who think their pronunciation is perfect, but they're actually kind of wrong.
It's very easy There are
only 5 voices, and unlike English, the sound
doesn't change But
if you want to be like me, you'll need to memorize a huge number of words.
If you want to watch anime without it,
vocabulary is everything.